[Music]
have you around you heartbroken yes I
have yes I've had it broken many times
actually man I've had my heart broken so
bad that it was just ripped to pieces
that that nobody could mend it what
happened we're pretty much engaged and
it just didn't go through I guess so
this was a month ago I don't really know
I guess just past this change and people
change so not over it well
[Music]
married for almost 20 years actually
technically sort of still a married
[Applause]
[Music]
a few children together and it just
he started kind of he started looking
for like I wasn't enough they start
looking for other other women and being
interested in other women
that's what broke my heart and I stayed
with him for a while longer and
everything but I finally did leave it
has got to be to the point where it was
becoming too much
[Music]
and their perception and stuff so I
ended up leaving I'm completely over it
yeah I've been I've been over it
probably for about four years four to
five years but plucking up the courage
to leave and
finding the time that was right because
I thought it would be difficult to leave
that was what took longer and you know
it's kind of in it for the kids and
whatnot but it just became to be the
point where even they could see that it
wasn't worth paying for herself dated
enough people have my brother
we're like long enough that my heart
broken and I'm not just like I meet
someone and like wow I love you so I
guess that's my answer
have you ever had your heart broken yes
I have what happened I found out that my
son who was eighteen years old was a
heroin
he's still alive he's 22 but as a mother
it was the most devastating thing that
I've ever felt in my entire life
can you give advice to other moms who
might be going through the same
yes always keep your child under your
thumb when they're young know where
they're at all the time always make sure
that their friends where they're going
that their friends you know their
friends and their where their say
they're going to be this is the first
guy ever like dated he was my supervisor
at work and who was older than me by
like 11 years and he had a son and he
has a son that's like five years old was
still living with the motherís child and
it was I guess seeing things that I
liked and I like fell for it and then
there were some good times like we
didn't learn from each other a log we're
from different cultures and
each other's family and he knows he's
the manipulator and stuff and he knows
that he's a compulsive liar and stuff
and sometimes when everyone around you
tells you this person is bad for you you
just see the good in them just think
like just make up excuses and say no but
like they have a good side to them they
have did this things for me and it's I
think the hardest part is usually just
memories like you're used to the person
and the comfort of them and just them
being there like that phone call when
you fall asleep with each other at night
or like gonna go yep a certain spot
together listen to the same song so like
getting out of the hobby like a ritual
is hard I think that's I think that's
part it's not the person themselves
there's plenty other people who have the
good qualities of that guy plus a bunch
more without the baggage you know it's
this girl that I really really loved I
asked her do one small favor for me
and she couldn't
and then she couldn't do it for even
though she made upon us
she made a promise that she would and
when I found out the truth that she
didn't keep it it destroyed me the favor
I just asked her to stay faithful she
end up having two kids by the same guy
so that's pretty yeah it it destroyed me
for a little while but then I got old
Here I am now today yes I've had my
heart broken for
well half a shock well I just gonna work
out I guess I just loved him a little
more than he loved me and
we're still friends kind of so they just
like I don't know we just went separate
ways it was mutually I kind of forced
myself to just get over him because well
he wasn't under Hormuz oh and you would
say you're fully over it no like I don't
think we overlooked forever like I'm how
to explain it I care for him you know
but it's like I can move on but like I
always like to have a place in my heart
you don't mean like kind of I don't hold
grudges
but it hurts in high school uh sixty
years old
yeah what happened yeah she dumped me
she didn't listen to me it was the
greatest thing on earth and she didn't
notice yeah I had my heart broken when
she was my very first girlfriend I
really was super into her I thought she
was my love and then she went to Europe
and she cheated on me with a bunch of
other people and I found out through her
best friend
yeah and that kind of stuff so but now I
have an amazing new girlfriend who has
loved my life and so much happier I was
dating this guy and he was great and we
were best friends and I thought it was
gonna go somewhere and one summer he
left for to go teach at this camp and
then I was expecting him to come back
because he was gonna come back to go to
school and then when he came back he was
like oh by the way like I brought this
girl to come live with me for like a few
weeks and I was like cool great and I
pretended like I didn't care but I hurt
me so bad yeah those when I got my
man I've had my heart broken so bad that
it was just ripped to pieces that that
nobody can mend it I was locked up I
felt like I had nowhere to go you know
what I just thought man what's the
answer to life you don't want to is this
all there was saliva
you know I hide drugs I tried
relationship I tried to uh you know
finding my identity out there in the
world I tried different things you know
wa but all just came to an end to a big
old empty hole to a point where you know
what I just found
that I didn't want to go on living no
more you know so I had suicidal
tendencies to say Manny if this is all
there is to life
I want out so I was contemplating taking
my own life but then one day all of a
sudden there was a man and his name was
Jesus Christ and he says you know what
he'll take the broken-hearted he'll take
those that have been just beat down just
broken by this world and just you know
downcast and he says that he says give
me your heart he goes and I will mend
your broken heart
day two the girl in high school it's
kind of first girlfriend had never had
date her for four months and I was in
love with her and all that and yeah one
day right before Valentine's Day I was
all kind of psyched up for that she
broke up with me and I was way too into
her
like just for my own emotional stability
like it's probably a good thing in the
long run I was pissed at the time but
she had actually broken up four broken
up with me for a guy that actually ended
up being her husband and they're really
great together
and I'm so glad I'm not with her because
we would not have picked her together
so I think that was a bullet dodged and
just
thing in the ground run
well anybody that's watching this I
would tell you it's terrible it takes a
while to get over but had it not worked
out that way I might still be back in
Tennessee but I ended up moving to Vegas
living in Southern California met the
girl of my dreams so it's all good in
the long run so you just got to hang in
there and roll the punches
[Music]